on poursuit cette édition spéciale ce
soir avec normande et carrick et
président et chef de la direction des
magasins serre et perles morency qui est
propriétaire du restaurant côté est à
kamouraska
bonsoir à vous deux monsieur gary on
vous a reçu un peu plus tôt dans l'année
votre année était bien sûr très
difficile parce que vous avez dû placer
votre entreprise même sous la protection
des tribunaux
comment allez vous aujourd'hui un an
plus tard ben j'avoue que c'est je pense
que beaucoup mieux
c'était une épreuve et on n'était
sûrement pas préparé à une telle
situation
mais tout compte fait ça va beaucoup
mieux et on est sur la bonne voie bon ça
fait ça fait quand même du bien à
entendre de votre côté père morency
quand on dit que les entrepreneurs
doivent se réinventer puis on entendu
souvent dans la bouche des politiciens
ce mot-là ce verbe là se réinventer vous
vous êtes en restauration
vous en êtes la perf la parfaite
démonstration n'est ce pas oui puisque
c'est la 9ème concept cette année ses
côtés est donc de piolenc s'est déployée
en neuf versions donc les milieux un
bassin je voudrais de livraison à
domicile marchés à l'extérieur
nous avons également fait du traitement
pour entreprises lancé gourmand caviste
on a fait le cantine extérieur donc
beaucoup beaucoup d'ajustements
j'écoutais à sa kamouraska cette année
donc beaucoup d'ajustements se
réinventer être très créatif
qu'est ce qui à normand décarie de votre
côté changé fondamentalement dans votre
façon de gérer vos affaires avec la
pandémie
le produit s'est avéré un accélérateur
nous on a vu l'intérêt l'intérêt subit
je vous dirai pour la clientèle affaires
du plein air de faire des activités
extérieures et évidemment on y
privilégie c'est ce qu'on fait c'est nos
activités principales c'est nos valeurs
alors on y privilégier dans ce sens où
on est en mesure de d'être là pour les
clientèles vous avez saisi l'occasion un
des sportifs
vous avez saisi l'occasion qui se
présentait oui oui on était opportuniste
mais la pandémie nous au fait on a dû
solliciter domaine
parce que bon on pouvait pas le prévoir
et oui on se réinventer comme disait
madame morency mais pour le bénéfice des
clients ont repositionné entreprise ça
nous force à faire d'apposer des gestes
par exemple toute la poche
omni canal où finalement tout la
transformation numérique qui nous permet
lorsque les magasins sont fermés de
garder le cap et d'être capable de
générer des ventes et des revenus
c'était quoi père morand si le facteur
le plus déterminant pour vous pour vivre
pour survivre comme entreprise depuis on
a définitivement notre capacité à
innover continuellement
c'était déjà mon pedigree
d'entrepreneurs de pouvoir m'adapter je
pense que c'est une force je vous dirais
même que avant le coc vide
ma faiblesse était peut-être mon hyper
diversification d'entreprise et joe
hollande mais c'est devenu ma grande
force
donc j'ai eu raison finalement la
pandémie me donner raison de d'avoir
distribué méheut dans plusieurs paniers
et aujourd'hui ça a été une année
difficile mais je m'en suis sorti et je
sais que je vais ressortir plus forts de
cette expérience c'est quand même la
chance d'avoir un restaurant en région
donc évidemment eu certains
assouplissements au niveau des ondes on
est innocent on d'orange en zone rouge
mais j'étais très focus et sur les d que
les gens allaient toujours manger tant
que ça soit dans un geste que ça soit la
formule pagny oui à domicile formule
marché gourmand qui avis sera donc c'est
vraiment cette capacité à me transforme
et que permis à côté s de devenir je
pense à quelque part un exemple ou du
moins une inspiration parce que on
entend beaucoup
histoire christ effectivement on entend
des histoires tristes et je crois qu'il
y en a beaucoup
d'ailleurs dans le secteur dans
l'économie dans le secteur de la
restauration notamment dans le secteur
du détail aussi la pandémie n'est pas
terminé il ya encore beaucoup de
restrictions
je vais vous entendre tous les deux sur
comment vous envisager la suite des
choses normand décarie écoutez la
fermeture de magasins pendant de
nombreuses semaines pour pas dire de
nombreux mois au fait des victimes non
pas des victimes directes
à cause de la pandémie à cause de deux
explosions mais des victimes parce que
des centaines de travailleurs qui ont
perdu leur emploi alors ça ça demande un
ajustement
il faut refaire nos choses progrès faire
nos glaces et on réalise une chose c'est
que la clientèle est lui beaucoup plus
patiente qu'elle était auparavant
ah ouais clientèle est là où la
clientèle est plus haute que je dirais
et nous on s'assure que on est
sécuritaire et notre environnement et
est tout à fait en règle avec lui les
mesures sanitaires
ça nous permet d'accueillir les clients
qui viennent en grand nom mais ça nous
permet de les accueillir dans le taux de
sécurité et aussi de sécuriser nos
employés qui nous aide à faire le
travail l'environnement sécuritaire nous
facilite la tâche père morency il y aura
encore des restrictions dans les
prochains mois et peut-être encore cet
été aussi même si vous êtes ouvert vous
prêt à vivre ça encore ben oui tout à
fait et je serais d'accord avec monsieur
décarie nos environnements sont
sécuritaires
je crois que les gens dans les
restaurants comme dans les magasins
respecte les règles donc il faut
maintenir nos entreprises ouvert
je comprends cette décision politique
restrictive est bon on pourrait en
débattre longtemps mais je crois quand
même que dans ces espaces vite les gens
sont très respectueux et c'est beaucoup
plus sécuritaire de maintenir ces lieux
ouverts qui a dit rassemblement plutôt
privé de façon illégale dans les maisons
donc je souhaite vraiment que nos
entreprises puissent rester ouverts je
pense que le plus
si c'est l'ignorance ne pas savoir sur
vos points restent ouverts
il faut vraiment que le gouvernement
nous assure qu'une puis sont restés
ouverts que nous puissions accueillir en
toute sécurité nos clients et donc pour
moi c'est l'affirmation est un peu
insensé
ok alors un plan de réouverture
certainement un calendrier ça viendra
peut-être dans les prochaines semaines
bonne chance pour la suite voilà c'est
ce que j'ai le goût de vous dire perdre
morency élus et norman décarie merci
beaucoup merci au plaisir simplement
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit